THE ROOKS ARE OUT IN FRONT WITH
32.
NOW THE CAVS.
>> THIS WAS YOUR PICK, BRIAN.
>> HOME COOKING.
>> AND YOU HEAR THE CROWD.
THE HOME FAVORITES.
DOES IT MATTER IF YOU MAKE THIS
FIVE?
WE SAW ANTETOKOUNMPO --
>> BY THE WAY, JARRETT ALLEN, 1
FOR 10 FROM THREE THIS YEAR.
AND MAYBE YOU SEE WHY.
>> OH!
>> THERE YOU GO!
YES!
SHOUT THEM UP.
HE WENT 31.
>> THAT'S A SPECIAL NUMBER.
COME ALIVE HERE.
HE IS GOING TO COME ALIVE.
>> JARRETT ALLEN IS WEARING A
MICROPHONE FOR US.
HE IS KEEPING IT QUIET.
>> THERE YOU GO.
>> HE DOES HAVE A SMOOTH STROKE.
>> GET ABOUT TEN.
>> GOOD CALL, REG.
>> A FIVE-POINT EFFORT BY
JARRETT ALLEN.
>> I'M JUST LOOKING AT MY
ROOKIES ON THE BENCH RIGHT NOW.
PLAYING AGAINST THESE OLD DUDES,
COME ON.
>> BY THE WAY, THIS IS REF CAM.
THIS IS INSIDE THE JERSEY OF OUR
OFFICIAL.
>> HOW COOL IS THAT?
>> KIND OF DOPE, RENTAL.
THEY WOULD HAVE CALLED ALL YOUR
MOVES.G.
MOVES.
THEY NEED A CAMERA ON JARRETT
ALLEN'S THROAT.
EVAN MOBLEY NEXT TO PLAY.
OH!
ANOTHER FIVE POINTER.
WE GOT A SHOOTER!
>> HE CAN SHOOT.
HE IS FROM THAT OTHER SCHOOL.
>> AND BRIAN, IT'S LOOKING GOOD
RIGHT NOW.
>> MAKING A RUN AT ROOKIE OF THE
YEAR THIS YEAR.
HE IS ON FIRE!
>> GIVE HIM ROOKIE OF THE
CAREER.
>> OH, MY GOODNESS.
FOUR-POINTER.
FIRST MISS.
DON'T GET YOUR OWN REBOUND.
THAT'S WHAT YOUR TEAMMATES ARE
FOR.
>> GET IT UP!
OH!
MAN, THAT'S NICE.
>> 18.
NOT AS GREAT.
I'M STANDING UP FOR THAT.
THAT'S GREAT.
AND NOW YOU HAVE YOUR BEST
SHOOTER LAST.
IN DARIUS GARLAND.
SMART STRATEGY BY THE CAVS.
GET THE TWO BIG GUYS OUT FIRST.
>> GET THE WEAKEST SUIT OUT OF
THE WAY FIRST.
THEN THE NEXT BEST SHOOTER.
NOW THE BEST SHOOTER.
>> HE HAS TO HAVE A 14 TO TIE
THE ROOKIES, RIGHT?
>> THAT'S RIGHT, 32 ON THE BOARD
FOR THE ROOKIES.
THIS THE FIRST CHALLENGE.
100 POINTS ON THE LINE HERE.
AND DARIUS GARLAND, FIRST-TIME
ALL-STAR THIS YEAR.
ALL HE NEEDS IS TEN POINTS TO
GET THE 100 CHALLENGE.
AND THAT'S A GOOD START RIGHT
THERE!
>> LOOK HOW HE WALKED IT, REG.
THAT'S NOTHING.
LOOK AT IT, REG!
>> IT'S A PUT AWAY.
>> PUT AWAY.
OH!
THAT'S IT.
HOMETOWN COOKING.
>> JUST FOR FUN HERE.
>> HOMETOWN COOKING.
>> TEAM CAVS HAVE 100 POINTS ON
THE BOARD AND THE CHALLENGE, AS
GARLAND FILLING IT UP.
ANOTHER ONE FROM FIVE-POINT
RANGE.
OH!
WAY TO REPRESENT.
>> AND IT'S ALL ABOUT THE
STRATEGY THOUGH.
I LOVED IT.
>> LET'S GET OUR BIG GUYS AND
"THE WEAKEST LINK" OUT OF THE
WAY FIRST.
AND THEN MAYBE ONE OF THE BETTER
BIG SHOOTERS IN MOBLEY.
BUT YOUR HOME RUN HITTER, DARIUS
GARLAND.
>> DIFFERENT STRATEGIES.
GIANNIS TRIED TO BE THE ONE WHO
STARTED.
YES, I WILL START THE TONE, SET
THE TONE AND IT DIDN'T WORK OUT.
THEY WENT THE OPPOSITE WAY.
GARLAND MADE 3-5 POINTERS AND
THREE THREE-POINTERS.
NICE RUN.
THEY TOOK ONE AWAY.
IT'S STI